hello hello what left that an
account level over there it's going very well
thank you and you even it's going well I have the
great pleasure of being able to discuss with
jessica jessica who lives in australia
noticeably poses at the moment I'm
on vacation  in france there on vacation in
france but so you have a series of
podcasts to teach broadcast
french called cross yeah if
i understand correctly then i have two friends
hidden fun xiaowei podcast fone horses
and its podcasts maybe the best
thing it would be if you can
introduce yourself a little yes that you invite
where france or australia and you are I
believe a teacher of french as a
foreign language but three hours
explain to us a little what your
activities do
good so me i'm  I'm calling jessica right
now I'm in France until the end
of the year to spend the end-
of-year holidays with my family at my mom's
but actually I'm an expatriate so
in melbourne in australia
and since then  four five years
now so i have two high castes so i
operate under the name of french your
way you can find the website
times the show and points as point has had
there you can find the podcasts
there are also many others  things in
fact I have articles tutorials
also world cheese with the answers
to practice French and all this
content there and free so the two
podcasts
frenchweb podcast so you should know that
for podcasts
you can find them online and on
my  website for the older ones
because the girl podcast only allows you to
view the 50 or 100 most recent
episodes and there are a lot more than that
at the moment
the podcasts are on hiatus because I
'm on maternity leave which is extending for
a year  a little longer than
expected because life with two children is
still very very demanding but I
will be back at the beginning of 2020 so
as they say stay tuned
stay tuned and see you  go find
new episodes for the moment there is
enough material to discover or
rediscover all the episodes that are
already online
so but there you are ten years old or 150
episodes
it's a lot it's a godsend I  I have
more than that because hot fan and
podcasts I have more than 200 it's a
weekly podcast that came out
every Wednesday and this one then I have I
speak in English because I am a
teacher of French as a foreign language
but  as I address all
levels I explain concepts in
English so you have to understand that these
are not lessons
I am not learning to help ready-
made sentences to repeat I am learning
I am teaching the mechanisms of  language
because what interests me I
love grammar
I'm not saying that grammar is everything
but what I do in podcasts
I like to dissect how things
work
so I explain notions of grammar
that  we may have assimilated and that we
p  had to reuse in a more or less
passive way but without having
really asked why and how the
same for vocabulary what my
listeners like is what
I also like is what makes my
signature  is explained the etymology
of the words or the history behind the words
and in fact all these things to that makes it possible
to understand and to may where he had
never seen it like that and that allows therefore
it facilitates the memorization that these
concepts  qu in English then
explained in English because my
approach is not to do a French lesson
with sentences everything is
hot fun and podcasts here and I
also answer questions from listeners
or  students who follow me and who
often write me emails with
particular difficulty asking me
how one chooses between who is that for
example and I explain what and
podcasts which are short episodes of man
about ten minutes
sometimes I overflow  a little bit I
have  if strategy advice for
learning how to memorize
vocabulary how to improve your
oral comprehension etc
here is for those who really want to work
not on the mechanics of the
language but on French so their
oral comprehension
how French is used
in everyday life  learn more
vocabulary etc this
is my other podcast which is
level plus so i have beginners who
have written to me that they started with this
and i take my hat off to them because
you still have to hang on  for me
it's more of
an intermediary in power a good start
years begins as a soloist but I would
still say intermediate to see progress
because these are interviews
of native French-speaking people therefore
French people French expatriates
Belgian Canadians etc who talk about their
passion or their profession the two
being that often being linked so there
it is your case are only in
French so you have to drive
the inter  view is only in French
what I wanted is that there is an
introduction that lasts about five
minutes it's been ten minutes where I speak
in English to give the context is
given a few key vocabulary words
that allow not to be so
specific key vocabularies
about the interview that allow you to be able to
listen directly
so sometimes I receive messages
but why not everything is in French
it's because my podcast is
for those people who need  a little
help to progress towards a
free understanding and to give them the
context for them it helps them enormously
are there also babies
as for you transcribed a
transcription yes then
there is the complete transcription of
each interview which  is available in
pdf so this one on the other hand for one you
can buy it for the price of about an
e-mail coffee and I believe 63 64 first
episodes are available inside
the transc  ription is available for
free on my website comes
with comprehension
and answer questions for others because
it took me a lot of time to do
the questions there is only the
transcript and so it just costs a
few dollars the podcasts the
interviews in it  - even everything that we
have access to on my website or on the
podcast application is free
it is only the written support which
makes it possible to finance in fact the
remuneration of the person it is the
transcription of course and is then the
specificity of this  podcast is that
it's a completely authentic conversation
I noticed that there was a lot of
I had actually looked at what
was being done a bit in the
French podcast market to learn
French and it was often
dialogues that were either completely
imagine so created to make the podcast
or places like muse in so
french which are also very good in fact
everyone has their attributes  outs in fact but there
are some who are therefore slowed down on articulated
to allow understanding
my objective I said yes no I believe
that this tax is a good initiative
because what is missing in all
languages
ironically French is  this kind
of content is spontaneous discussions
which are first of all
discussions of conversations and which
are then transcribed here because
otherwise if you are a girl first and then
you stop recording your
artificial fact in the treaty will have  the eldest
are not the same language we do
not use the same words at the legion and
especially especially in the congresses his
natural passion we use more
my age of bordeaux high frequency so
finally it becomes easier I
had the  experience in many languages
when we do things for beginners
they and the words that are
used frequently they appear very often
because they are of high frequency
and then everything becomes  of low
frequency there is not much difference
is not so many words to take
but all the same in discussions
natural conversation using a
less but urged vocabulary so it
makes for intermediates this ideal
as continues so I salute it
by the way is this  that we can use
familiarity of course there is no problem
I just have to remember it
but in I think it is a very
good
initiative and the transcriptions are
also important
and moreover this  would be things
perhaps that we could offer a high
member with precisely because we
miss so much any momentum of you
intermediate content and ccs may but there I
wonder if we can not therefore separate the
file according to the
Dutch introduction  of the part therefore which is
entirely in French well which
allows an agent of those who loop
in the listening but often you have to
listen several times so
introduction we do not want to listen to it
while the conve  rsation we
will listen to it five times that's what I say
when I get a message from
someone who says yes well why is it
in English or the noise sorry because
I know it's useful to those who  are
the most intermediate or and who
need that little boost
just skip the first five or ten
minutes of the podcast
yes sometimes I toyed with the idea of
doing my introduction in
simpler French but that distorts it  idea and
what is interesting is that aubin
but my students my listeners
know me and know my way of
speaking
I have a fairly clear pronunciation
because I am also a language teacher
and therefore interview others
people we really have a variety
of language registers of accents of
personality style which transpires because there
are people who are very cool who
use a lot of daring and then we
have people who are a little more intellectual
intellectual point a vocabulary
much p  read sustained and the stories
are really exciting
it goes from the airline pilot to the mayor of my
hometown where the space when the time comes
it's sensational sensational if
I enter it's the miss is delighted we want to
know how the French people
live  what do they do what does he
think it's sfr the french the
chocottes
the francophones and there is excellent
méchoui
that's why I asked is
it possible technically to separate in the
sound file beautiful  the introduction in
English to have files that you
can listen to and re-listen to several times
to be able to understand because there are
always ddds the disappointment part
of the conversation
what you don't understand it would be
great fun it would be great  idea
maybe two
to record the introduction to by wadi
to post it separately for people who
go directly to the heart
of the subject and in French had never
thought of that but yes because often
me when I want for example  the a
little short or disadvantage of the
series at 6000 is that it's only
in the target language while you
feel how the ring mbc
always has english in
the recording
there are a lot of people  who
take the trouble to separate the use
software to separate the English to
limit them so that they can listen
three four five times to the part in
French or in the target language when
I believe that being since you who
control what you  do that would be a
good idea to
separate english luke french because there
is english we will listen to it once finished
yes it's a good suggestion
what do you think you are
killing yourself  100% in the target language when you
afterwards yeah because the difficulty
is to explain the grammar to them
since we don't necessarily have we do
n't necessarily know the metalanguage
so the words used to describe the
grammar in the target language
and then  we don't necessarily have this
useful to know it but I think
they explained the mechanisms it is
important also
we are going to have a discussion afterwards to
target you on the libe podcast I
think most people prefer and
explanations in English good balloons
but there are  a lot of people
including me who don't want
an explanation in the language actors
dati at it is what I prefer me
is to do all these discussions
in the language but after having had
the experience with talent so we have for
example  alain bonadéi what we call
the historical mines, that is to say the
stories made simple with a lot of
competitions especially a lot of
repetitions of the most common terms
and but after that it becomes interesting
to know more about things of which we
has already had experience but there I
prefer to do it in france is in my
opinion if the spot in the spend is there
because there are two types of audience
on the do also m
interesting to have discussions s
ur grammar on the etymology of words
but in French so the person can
choose
well you seem to have a lot of things to
do that's what I'm telling you in front of the
time to do it it can be an
idea
ok I I  i would like to know
how what prompted you to
create this kind of material that it is
a little time finally the story of
the story
i think that being in a family
of is good  elsewhere i have an episode of
fringe or here it must be 21 or
something like that where i'm
talking about
my childhood my story how i got to
where i am today because
i was interviewed by a radio  local
in Australia and this recording is
available it's one of the podcasts
but basically I come from a family where there
are several teachers I'm the daughter
of a teacher too so it's true
that teaching has always been a
small  bit second nature to me and at
first I studied English
I thought I was going to be a teacher.  I do
n't know French as
a foreign language at all.
French I will
use English to travel to live
in other countries where it was the
perfect combination so I worked
in different in different schools
in different French centers in
different countries of the world in particular in
the network or well known  alliances
françaises
i work in ireland in trinidad and
tobago 2 years in china
i met my husband now who
is australian so i moved
to australia will be there soon 10 years 1
2 that and it's not easy to  to be
a good French teacher
so we are offered I say from one
term to another in the alliances
françaises for example you never know
how many hours you will have in the event
of an accident or absence is true that you don't
'East  not necessarily finally the status is
a little precarious on the whole so I
started to give so to launch
myself on my own so register french
way and I started by giving
private lessons or in very small groups which
were in  at home or or online on
skype
and then i started to have this desire
to reach an audience that was not
only located in melbourne i
had this idea of ​​making 6 flinch
compared to the content i was seeing
in podcasts  who did
n't always satisfy me precisely because it was
n't authentic and so I wanted to
do his interviews because you have to
know that
the benefits come from both sides
because the students are very
interested and are making real progress
learn that  is interesting it's
different and I love making fans
here's what because it allows me to
discover and talk with
people who I would never have talked to and
to learn a lot of things myself
on subjects that  I don't know so
I like that a lot and I really did that
I think that when you do
when you feel in pau class projects
and it's because it takes a
lot of time and it's free
you have to  to be passionate also because we
do so that's very important
and then the dimension of teaching
French
more generally it's done like that
naturally and online especially since
the birth of bain my first child
and then the second because  i
need this flexibility to be able to
be with them full time mom
full time to see them grow and then
on my little free time continue to
create resources and communicate with
the people who follow me who are
registered at  the newsletter that send
me emails that they send me
questions and then try to meet
their needs yes as best as
possible
so that's what really satisfies me
which is very
interesting and I believe  that you and  me
and many others are part of a
new wave new way
of teaching languages ​​so
there are ends and
entrepreneurs people who are getting started and who teaches
with one more pass makes six
target plates often more authentic and
appeal addressed to everyone everyone is
defending koffi again thread of people who
see
French there and we could I have to discuss
a body pure happiness possibility true
that we are going to do a podcast huawei does not have
a dog so it's  on the other channel
but what do I mean I still want to
explore with you after the
possibility of tiko in collaboration
with fred frith to be able to offer these
relics to our members and we have
to agree on the terms  to the
movement the modalities and the players
it would be very interesting for our
standards because precisely it is the
kind of content that is missing which is
clicked which targets the intermediaries and
which allows which allows people
to learn about badly an but as  you
just said to learn a lot of
things about different people how
they live what to do what they
think and maybe it's
because we have to talk for between 30
minutes
maybe I'll finish  there our
discussion and but we will continue the
discussion on the possibilities the
modalities of a
possible cooperation in the future
thank you I congratulate you for
what you are doing besides you by
a very clear French and it is very
important
eventually you have to know how to
understand people who by paillot who have a
less clear pronunciation who have a
way of thinking - but that's because
it's professional deformation
I said to myself I understand too
but you have to start with  people who
are understandable to each
other afterwards we have to change
yes yes I'm going to run
again good he's holding on hockey see you soon
so in position soon machine and
then I'm waiting for just that's it
ok thank you goodbye g/100 g
[Music]